[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العلوي
الملك سلمان يوقعوا مع الرئيس الصيني
اتفاقيه الشراكه الاستراتيجيه الشامله بين
البلدين
والرئيس يقول ان زيارته للسعوديه تفتح
وعصرا جديدا للعلاقات مع العرب
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه وقع
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز
اتفاقيه الشراكه الاستراتيجيه الشامله بين
البلدين
وجاء ذلك خلال استقبال الملك سلمان الرئيس
الصيني في قصر اليمامه في الرياض
استعراض علاقات الصداقه التاريخيه بين
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وجمهوريه الصين الشعبيه وسبل تعزيزها بما
يخدم مصالح البلدين والشعبين الصديقين في
شتى المجالات
وكان ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان قد عقد جلسه مباحثات مع الرئيس
الصيني في جنبيك في قصر اليمامه بالرياض
وقد اعرب ولي العهد السعودي في بدء
المباحثات عن ترحيبه بزياره الرئيس الصيني
الى المملكه
وشهدت القمه السعوديه الصينيه التوقيع على
خطه المواءمه بين رؤيه المملكه 2030
ومبادره الحزام والطريق كما وقع البلدان
على مذكره تفاهم في مجال الطاقه
الهيدروجينيه وتشجيع الاستثمار المباشر
وشملت الاتفاقيات المتوقعه كذلك مذكره
تعاونا في مجال الاسكان واخرى خاصه بتعليم
اللغه الصينيه
وقد استعرض الملك سلمان مع الرئيس الصيني
بحضور ولي العهد على خط الصداقه التاريخيه
بين البلدين وسبل تعذيزها في المجالات
كافه
خلال ثلاثه عقود اتخذت الصين مكانتها
كاحدى اكبر القوى الاقتصاديه في العالم بل
ثمها تحديدا فالصين طبقت سياسه التعلم من
اخطائها الكثير حينها لتصبح تجربتها مثالا
قابلا للاسقاط على بعض الاقتصاديات
المنهكه في دول تملك الموارد
مستنقع الحروب الذين حاصر التنين الصيني
للسنوات اخرجه اكثر شراسه ووضعه بمصاف
الاقتصادات الاولى عالميا والسبيل لذلك
وفق دراساتنا سياسه التعلم من الاخطاء في
الصين تملصت من براثن مجاعه لتتحول خلال
ثلاثه عقود فقط الى ثاني اكبر اقتصاد في
العالم بعد معالجتها لثلاثه اخطاء
اولها الوثبه العظيمه التي كان يرجى منها
تحويل البلاد من الزراعه الى التصنيعه
لكنها تسببت بمجاعه راحه ضحيتها الملايين
في الخمسينيات القرن الماضي ان الخطا
الثاني الذي ارتكبه الزعيم الصيني فكان
الثوره الثقافيه بهدف التخلص من معارضه في
الحزب الشيوعيه ثوره اوصلت الولاده لحافه
الانهيار وتسببت بتراجع الدخل الفرديه الى
اقل من 200 دولار سنويا
فيما ثالث الاخطاء يتمثل بالحروب ثلاث
مواجهات مسلحه محدوده زمنيا ومكنيا بين
عام 62 و 79 استنزفت قدرات البلاد
الاقتصاديه وانهكتها هذه الاخطاء علمت
القاده الجدد عدم تطوير الاقتصاد عبر
الصدمات بل اتمامه تدريجيا ليعتده الشعب
ثم تطبيق سياسه الانفتاح على الاستثمار
الاجنبي والقطاع الخاص وتبني النظام
الاقتصاديه الراسمالي في مفارقه غريبه
لبلد شيوعيه وبعد ان كان نصيبها من الناتج
الاجمالي العالمي لا يتجاوز واحدا فاصل
ثمانيه في المئه عام
حققت قفزه النوعيه مع ارتفاع هذا الرقم
الى 16% عام 2020 اي ان اقتصادها تضاعف
نحو تسع مرات خلال اقل من سبعه عقود كما
اصبح القطاع الخاص يساهم بن 60% من
الاقتصاد الصيني
ورغم ان تجربه الصينيه غير قابله للاسقاط
بحذافيرها على اقتصادات منهكه لبعض الدول
العربيه بسبب اختلاف بعدد السكان والمساحه
والموارد الطبيعيه لكنها اكثر قابليه
للتطبيق في بعض الدول خاصه تلك التي تجمع
بين الموارد الطبيعيه والبشريه والاستقرار
السياسيه وتستطيع البدء في السير في طريق
التنميه
اخرى للصين تتمثل بطريق الحريق مبادره
قدمها الرئيس الصينيه عام 2013 وتهدف
لاعاده احياء الطريق التجاري القديم
الواصل بين الصين واوروبا والشرق الاوسط
الحزام والطريق او ما يعرف بطريق الحرير
الجديد يحاكم على المخزن الصيني منذ عام
2013 هذه النسخه الصينيه محدثه وتقوم على
انقاذ احد اقدم طرق التجاره واهمها لاكثر
من 1500 سنه مضت
حياكه هذا المشروع وصفت بالتاريخيه لانه
الاكبر من حيث تمويل البنيه التحتيه
والاستثمارات والابعاد السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه
يغطي الطريق الذي يفوق طوله 10,000 كم
اكثر من 66 دوله اين يقرب من ثلثي سكان
الارض
ينطلق من الصين مرورا بكزاخستان وايران
وتركيا ثم روسيا وصولا الى المانيا
وهولندا وايطاليا وثانيهما يشق طريقه بحرا
من الصين الى فيتنام وماليزيا والهند
ويكمل طريقه باتجاه سريلانكا و كينيا ليصل
الى اليونان وايطاليا
[موسيقى]
يحدث احياء الطريق الى اعاده فتح القنوات
بين الصين وجيرانها في الغرب خصوصا اسيا
الوسطى والشرق الاوسط واوروبا وبالتالي
ايصال بضائعها باسهل واسرع طريقه ممكنه
لجميع قارات العالم تاريخ الانتهاء
المستهدف للمشروع هو عام 2049 والذي
سيتزامن مع ذكر المئويه لتاسيس جمهوريه
الصين الشعبيه تقدر تكلفته بين اربعه
تريونات وثمانيه مليون دولار وما يتضمنه
ذلك من تشييد شبكات من السكك الحديديه
وانابيب نفط وغاز وخطوط كهرباء وانترنت
وبناء تحتيه
وفي وقت ينظر لمبادره الحزام والطريق على
انها فرصه لتاسيس محرك نمو عالمي جديد
يربط القارات تتخوف الولايات المتحده ودول
اوروبيه من ميل ميزان القوه الاقتصاديه
لصالح الصين اما الامال الروسيه فمعقوده
على حاجه الصين الى عبور اراضيها نحو
اوروبا والى مصادر الطاقه مصالح مشتركه
تجعل البلدين حلفين سياسيين
[موسيقى]
الى المركز الاعلامي للقمه السعوديه
الصينيه مع الزميل نايف الاحمري نايف
يعطيك الف عافيه الميكروفون لك والضيوفك
الله يعافيك شكرا دكتور يعطيك العافيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه النافذه التي
نضل عليكم منها هنا في المركز الاعلامي
المصاحب لقمم الرياض اذا تبعنا واياكم منذ
قليل توقيع اتفاقيه الشراكه الاستراتيجيه
الشامله بين السعوديه والصين الاتفاقيه
التي وقعت همم بحضور الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز العاهل السعودي والرئيس الصيني
شيجن ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان بجمله من المحادثات والمباحثات
الثنائيه التي تم استعراض فيها العلاقات
التاريخيه بين البلدين الصديقين بين الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز وايضا الرئيس الصيني
شيء بحضور ولي العهد السعودي الذي اجراه
كذلك ايضا مباحثات رسميه وقع ايضا كذلك مع
الرئيس الصيني عددا من اتفاقيه اتفاقيات
ومذكرات تعاون وتفاهم في مجالات الاسكان
في
كذلك اا بتعليم اللغه الصينيه همم التعاون
والمساعده القضائيه كذلك في المسائل
المدنيه والتجاريه همم كذلك السعوديه
والصين وقعت على مذكره التفاهم في مجال
الطاقه الهيدروجينيه رويترز كانت قد نقلت
قبل قليل بان السعوديه وقعت اتفاقا مع
هواوي الصينيه في مجال الحوسبه السحابيه
ارحب هنا بضيوف الاستاذ سامي النصف وزير
الاعلام الكويتيه السابق اهلا وسهلا فيك
سامي وكذلك الدكتور عبد المنعم همم سعيد
دكتور عبد المنعم مرحبا بك معي جمله من
الاتفاقيات
المختلفه المتنوعه ايضا كذلك في مجالات
الاسكان التعليم بكذلك الطاقه وايضا حتى
في التقنيه كيف يمكن النظر لها
دكتور
الاستفاده الكبيره من هذا اللقاء يعني انا
متاكد انه كل ما استمعنا اليه اليوم جرى
بحثه خلال الشهور الماضيه بالتفاصيل
كبيره للاستفاده من التجربه الصينيه
التجربه الصينيه من اغنى التجارب في تاريخ
الدول الناميه في العالم لانه الصين كانت
مثال للفقر والمجاعه
والثورات العنيفه والحروب الاهليه كل هذه
الامور اللي عانتها كثيرا الدول الناميه
في العالم الى حاله كبيره من الاستقرار
التعامل على مساحه كبيره من الارض تزيد عن
9 مليون كيلو متر مربع مع عدد سكان مليار
و400 مليون
نقله حوالي لمليار من البشر من الفقر الى
الستر دي تجربه عميقه جدا جرت في الصين
همم ومن ثم الاستفاده بها لانه كما نعرف
ان الصين لها فوائد في الميزان التجاري مع
دول العالم تقريبا دوله حققت احتياطيات
ضخمه ثري بوينت فايف او 3.5
تريليون دولار بسبب الفائض في الميزان
التجاري على المستوى العالمي والدوله
بسواء دول كبيره زي الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه او دول صغيره في في في العالم
فانا عايز اقول الاستفاده من هذه التجربه
امر مهم جدا لانها ايضا نحن في حاله جديده
من النضج في هذه التجربه الصينيه بمعنى ان
الصين تدخل الان مجالات كبيره جدا لها
علاقه بالاقتصاد الاخضر لا علاقه بالفضاء
لا علاقه زي الاتفاق اللي تم مع هواوي
الخاص بموضوع تخزين المعلومات في ال- ال-
ال- ال- السحاب زي ما
بيسموه الان الصين تدخل في مرحله
الفضائيات الخاصه
بمركبات فضائيه مستقره داخل الفضاء او على
القمر الصين التجربه لكن ايضا احنا عندنا
في العالم العربي الان زي ما ذكرنا في
مرات السابقه الحاله الاصلاح الموجوده في
حاله من قوه الدفع الكبيره الجاريه اللي
تجعلنا نتقبل الكثير من هذه الامور والتي
تعطينا فيها الصين خبره والتي ايضا من
ناحيتنا يوجد لدينا القواعد العلميه
والقواعد البشريه المستعده لاستقبال هذا
الموضوع ده بيخلينا لا نقول للعالم ان انا
لا نقبل الاحتكار فقط
للمعرفه او للامور وانما ايضا بنسع الى
وجود عالم جديد قائم على التعاون في
مجالات ليس مكانها الان وانها مكانها ايضا
للمستقبل التجربه الصينيه التي تتحدث عن
الدكتور عبد المنعم سعيد كيف يمكن لدول
الخليج العالم العربي ان يستفيد منها هل
هناك ما يجب ان يؤخذ وما يجب ان يترك
برايك فيه بالاغلب ما يؤذي يكون في تجربه
او زاويه عند الصين علينا ان نتعلم منها
الصين كم يعني اقتصاده قائم على الحكومه
الكبيره
دوله الجميع يتوظف بها من المهد الى اللحد
ثم تغيرت
بالتسعينات توماس
ريدمن كتب وانا شاهدته بالكويت انه لو
تحولت الصين الى اقتصاد السوق سيرمي 400
مليون بدون سيفتي نت احنا ما عندنا شيوعيه
بس عندنا انظمه اقرب للشوعيه تعرف يعني
الدول الخليجيه بالاقلب الحكومه الكبيره
هي من يوظف بالاقلب القطاعات المتعدده
وبالتالي هذه التجربه بالصين اللي تحولت
من الحكومه الكبيره من الحكومه اللي توظف
الجميع الى القطاع الخاص اعتقد تجربه
جزيره بالدراسه الامر الثاني الصين كانت
دوله قائمه على الروماتيرز على المواد
الخام حتى في ال 85 كانت تصدر 35% من
النفط الخاص فيها تحولت بعد ذلك الى ما
نجمع او نريد ان نقوم به بالمملكه
وبالخليج وبدول العربيه النص ان نتحول من
اقتصاد لاستثمار والاموال بالاسهم
والسندات اللي ليست بديل حقيقي للنفط لو
انخفض النفط ماذا افعل بهذه الاسهم
والسندات المفروض نتحول الاقتصاد الحقيقي
هذه كذلك تجربه نستفيد بها من الصين الصين
اليوم هي مصنع العالم الصين لديها الهايتك
تكنولوجيا الهواوي والجي 5 او غيره وكذلك
راح تساعدنا طيب انا اعتقد انه ما انا
راها الان اخي الفاضل هي شهاده وفاه
لانظمه قديمه تقوم على الحكومه الكبيره
على حاديه القطبيه وغيرها وولاده نظام
عالمي جديد رايح يكون التعاون هو عنوانه
والمشيت وبالتالي هذا مستوى السياسه فقط
تذكر بهذه الاخبار
العاجله نجاح وسط السعوديه الاماراتيه
المشتركه في اتمام تبادل سجن امريكا
وروسيا نجاح الوساده قادها رئيس الامارات
الشيخ محمد بن زايد وولي عهد السعوديه
الامير محمد بن سلمان لتبادل مسجونين بين
واشنطن وموسكو البيان السعودي الاماراتي
المشترك اعلن نجاح وساطه التبادل السجناء
والتي تعكس علاقات الصداقه مع امريكا
وروسيا وصول الامريكيه جرينر عبر طائره
خاصه من موسكو الى ابو ظبي وصول الروسي
فيكتور عبر طائره خاصه من واشنطن الى ابو
ظبي اسالك هنا دكتور عبد المنعم عن
الدور السياسي الثقل السياسي اليوم همم
دول مثل المملكه العربيه السعوديه مثل
دوله الامارات العربيه المتحده وكذلك مصر
الى اي مدى تنظر اليه بكين بعين الاهتمام
بعين الاهميه
وبانه همم ربما شريك استراتيجي مهم في ثقه
السياسي وليس فقط الاقتصادي
يعني هو الدول العربيه من مصلحتها من
العالم يهدى فضلا عنه هدوء المنطقه الشرق
الاوسط نفسها يعني لازال عندنا حروب في
سوريا في اليمن في ليبيا يعني في اماكن
كثيره يعني في المنطقه لكن ايضا العالم
كله ملتهب للغايه بفعل الحرب الاوكرانيا
الخطوه التي قامت بها دوله الامارات
والسعوديه في مساله تبادل
جنين ما بين بلدين بتبقى يعني خطوات ربما
هنا فرد وهنا فرض انها بتبدا بتاليين
المواقف اا النداء الذي قام به الرئيس
السيسي في قمه شرم الشيخ للدول لحل الازمه
الاوكرانيه قادت الى اتفاق على مفاوضات
روسيه امريكيه فيما يخص بالاسلحه
الاستراتيجيه بعد كده روسيا نقصت في هذا
الاتفاق لكن اعتقد ان الجهد الى يزال
مستمر هي محاوله لتفكيك شويه الوضع المعقد
والملتهب والمشتعل الموجود في العالم
حاليا من خلال خطوات بسيطه لعوده الحديث
ما بين روسيا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
استاذ سامي همم يعني الدكتور عبد المنعم
يصف الوضع الاوضاع السياسيه بين اوضاع
يعني ربما ملتهبه مضطربه كذلك ال- ال-
الوضع يعني ينسحب على الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
ارتفاع نسبه تبخهم تبعات ايضا اقتصاديه
لجائحه كورونا وحتى للازمه الروسيه
الاوكرانيه هنا هل هي فرص يجب ان تستغل مع
هذه الازمات من قبل الدول وازنا مهمه
اقتصاديا مثل بكين والرياض مثلا وفي اي
نقاط يمكن ان يتم التقاء اغتنام هذه الفرص
شوف خلفه هذا الاستراتيجيا اسوا ما يمكن
ان يحدث لمنطقتنا المنطقه الخليجيه
والحرابيه هو خيارين اما ان تختفي من
الاضواء وبالتالي لا يشعر العالم بما يجري
لديك هذه قضيه خطره جدا والان لله الحمد
والمنه قاعدين نشوف لنا الاضواء كلها تسلط
قبل مده كنا في جده والان في الرياض
والاضواء مسلطه الامر الثاني سيء ان يكون
تسليط الاضواء اليك بالامور السالبه
للحروب الاهليه يعني لا يسمع من المنطقه
الا حروب وارهاب الان احنا نعطي بديل
اليوم العالم كله مسلط الاضواء الا
المنطقه الا الرياض انما ياتي منها
اتفاقيات همم قضايا بعيده كل البعد عن
القضايا والمشاكل السياسيه والانسدادات
والخروقات الامنيه الان نتكلم عن عالم
جديد يخلق بالرياض يخلق بتاريخ اليوم اللي
هو ال- ال- العالم القائم على المصالح
ونمل انه هذه القضايا وهذه الاتفاقيات
ستدخل اطراف ودول اخرى لها وبالتالي سنشهد
ال ال الكثير من تخفيف الازمات وتصفير
المشاكل ما نريد بالخليج والمنطقه العربيه
الدعي هو صفر مشاكل مع الجيران مع المجتمع
الدولي مع العالم اجمع وبالتالي هذه
الاتفاقيات هذه الزياره تعكس هذه التوجهات
الجديده بعكس ما كان عليه الامر قبل سنوات
طوال عندما كانت الايدولوجيا والتحالفات
التي نستقصد بها طرف ضد الطرف هذه انتهت
هذه شهاده ولاده جديده على قضيه المصالح
اعتقد ان المملكه دول الخليج الدول
العربيه الصين ستستفيد كثيرا من هذه
الاتفاقيات اللي راح تكون اقرب لسكن في
العالم لامريكا اللاتينيه لافريقيا لدول
اسيا انه ذهبوا الى علاقه المصالح وتكون
قمه الرياض وقمه من الرياض كذلك اضاءه
وقدوه وطريقه لماذا تذهب القيادات لزياره
دوله دوله لماذا لا تجتمع دول شرق اسيا
ويزورها الرئيس بايدا مثلا لخلق تفاهمات
مع مجموعه الدول والحال كذلك بافريقيا
واوروبا وغيره سياسه صفر مشاكل التي تتحدث
عنها الاستاذ سامي يوسف الدكتور عبد
المنعم هل يمكن ان تخلق عبر هكذا قمم عبر
هكذا زيارات عبر هكذا يعني تجمع اقليمي
عربي صيني كذلك وجود لامناء همم من عدد من
المنظمات الدوليه الوازنه والمهمه
يعني اكون صريح معاك يعني ليس ان في حياتي
يعني انه ال ال العالم سيكون في صفر مشاكل
على الاقل في المنطقه احنا لدينا
مشاكل متجدره على مستوى الكره الارضيه
كلها كل الذي تملكه ان مجموعه من الدول
اللي عندها القدر من العزيمه والقياده
انها تبدا في تغيير هذا الواقع واول تغيير
للواقع بيكون داخل كل بلد يعني ما لم يكن
التحديث الذي يجري في السعوديه لا توجد اي
مصداقيه لاي عمل خارجي او في مصر او في
الاردن او في المغرب او بقيه دول الخليج
هناك فعلا جهد لاعاده بناء هذه الدول على
مجتمع عصري حديث يستطيع ان هو يعتمد على
نفسه في امور كثيره ويتبادل مع العالم
امور مفيده بما فيها السعي للتعامل مع
المشاكل العالميه الحارقه يعني احنا لحظه
توتر شديده جدا في موضوع الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه كلا الطرفين يعني متمترس في
موقفه بالعكس هناك عمليات تصعيد سواء في
المطالب او في الاستخدامات الكثيفه
للاسلحه عندما تبدا في انك انت تعيد صياغه
الصراع الروسي الاوكراني الى انه مشكله
روسيه امريكيه ومكانت روسيا في العالم عن
طريق خطوه زي استئناف محادثات الاسلحه
الاستراتيجيه او تبادل السجناء او انك انت
عامله كده زي الخطوات اللي اتعملت في
بدايه لما كان اتعملت يعني لعب البينج
بونج في الصين كان اول بدايه الحديث
الصيني الروسي زمان في سبعينيات القرن
الماضي الان انت بتحاول ان تخرج من المازر
اللي فيه الكون دلوقت بعد ازمه الارهاب
ازمه الكرونه ازمه الحرب الاوكرانيه من
انك انت تخلق خطوات بسيطه يحدث فيها نوع
من الترطيب بيسمح بالحديث تحدث الدكتور
عبد المنعم عن النموذج السعودي اليوم
والاقتصادي التحولات التي حدثت في
السعوديه الاصلاح الاقتصادي وربما ذكر
الدكتور عبد المنعم بانه ما يحتاج اليه
اليوم همم يعني المنطقه والعالم العربي
ايضا بكذلك هل اصبح فعلا هذا النموذج همم
السعودي همم ملهما مهما لدى هذه الدول
العربيه لكي تتخطى المشاكل الاقتصاديه
التي افرزتها همم الحروب جائحه كورونا
الازمه الروسيه ايضا حتى الاوكرانيه وفي
علاقاتها ايضا وقيادتها للعالم العربي
ولخليج كذلك
انشغال اهو شوف الشباب لا يمكن ان يبقى ما
بين الاذن اليمنى واليسرى فضاء يعني ما ان
تشغلهم بالايديولوجيا وما شاهدناه من شباب
صحوه ذهبوا الى مشارق الارض ومقاربها يقتل
ويقتلوا وغيرها او نشغلهم التجربه
السعوديه اللي هي الاشغال بالتنميه
الاشغال بامور ايجابيه وعندما نتحدث حتى
عن صفر مشاكل نعم في عالم مثالي قد نصل
الى هذا انما لو استطعنا انه نقلل المشاكل
بالمنطقه من 10 مشاكل الى خمس هذا انجاز
كبير لاطفال الحرائق في سوريا مثلا وبقيت
في ليبيا هذا افضل من ان تبقى الحرائق في
سوريا وليبيا وبالتالي المثال السعودي
كذلك بالانفتاح الى الاخر قضيه هامه جدا
يعني اليوم بعض الدول بالمنطقه الدول
الاقليميه اللي نعلمها جميع اشكال هذه
الاكبر هو بالايدلوجيا هي لا تستطيع ان
تتعايش مع الاخر لديها مشاكل مع المجتمع
الدولي مع قوى زي الولايات المتحده على
الاوروبي وغيره وغيرها وبالتالي هذا
المثال السعودي اعتقد هو المثال اللي يجب
ان يسوق بالعالم العربي جربنا منذ
الخمسينات تجارب عربيه فاشله وانتهت
بهزائم عسكريه وامور كثيره انا اتصور ان
هذا المثال القدوه في لربما حتى زاويه
هامه للموضوع انظر الى تعامل العالم بقواه
الكبرى مع المثال السعودي انظر الى تجاوب
الولايات المتحده الاتحاد الاوروبيه الان
الصين حتى روسيا حتى قضيه التوسط اللي
ذكرتها في بدايه الحديث
ان العالم يحترم كثيرا هذا النوع من
التحرك اللي لا يتخندق في قضايا مطروح اما
يذهب ويحاول ان يكون على مسافه واحده من
الاطراف انا اتصور ان انا جربنا المثال
الاخر جربنا التخندق جربنا التخندق يمينا
وشمالا وحدثت همم المعارك البارده
والساخنه العربيه نذكر ما حدث اليمن قبل
الستينات نذكر ما حدث في علاقه الدول
العربيه العربيه بعضها البعض الى ان وصلنا
الى نتيجه ان هذا النوع من
الحراك لا ينفعنا من ثم نحن امام مود
الجديد نظام عالمي جديد السعوديه تقوده
واعتقد الدول العربيه ممكن ان تكسب الكثير
من التعلم الدكتور عبد المنعم توقيع
الاتفاقيه همم الشراكه الاستراتيجيه
الشامله بين البلدين بين السعوديه والصين
بحضور الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز الرئيس
الصيني شيء همم ما الذي تعنيه في دلالاتها
محدداتها بالنسبه للسعوديه اولا وللمنطقه
كذلك
لكن مقامات الذين وقعوا عليها يجعلني اقول
ان انا شيء جد وخطير لكن ايضا انه عنصر
موازن لان
الصين سابقا عقدت مثل هذه الشراكه مع
ايران فهنا اعتقد ان علينا ان احنا ننظر
جيدا
للاتفاقيه
ونراها على انها خطوه متقدمه لان الصين
هنا هنا التي تقبل على المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لكي تعقد مثل هذه الشراكه
وبالتالي الجزء هنا يبتدا نوع من التوازن
ما بين اتفاقيه كانت موجوده مع ايران ولها
علاقه بالنفط ولها علاقه
بامدادات صناعيه وتجاريه ما بين الطرف
الصيني والطرف الايراني بينما كانت بين
الولايات المتحده والمملكه قائمه على انه
المملكه تقدم الجزء الاكبر من الامدادات
الطاقه بالنسبه للسيد وجود هذه الشراكه
يعني نوع من التبادل ما بين الدولتين في
نوع من الارتقاء في مستوى العلاقه هل ده
يخلق نوع جديد من التوازن هل يجعل نوع من
التشاور نوع من الوساطه
ااا هناك امور كثيره يمكن ان تنتج عن مثل
هذا الامر عندما نعرف التفاصيل الخاصه به
والاجراءات العمليه المرتبطه بتطبيقات
تتحدث عن تفضل
انه نحن لا نقارن التفاح بالتفاح لو قارنا
الاتفاقيه الصينيه الايرانيه مع الاتفاقيه
الصينيه السعوديه ايران كانت في وضع بائس
ويائس ومنعت من التصدير وبالتالي عندما
تفاوضت مع الصين كانت في موقف ضعف حتى
انها وصلت الخصومات للصين الى 35%
كانت وبالتالي انا اتصور انه هذا الوضع
السعوديه ليست في وضع محاصر ولا بالعكسيه
قاعده تعكس قضيه ان التحرك السعودي يشمل
التحرك الخليجي والعربي وبالتالي هذه
زاويه للموضوع اعتقد انه ربما تكون مختلفه
هلا قضيه الهامه الثانيه انه نعم
الاتفاقيه دون مثل ما ذكر الدكتور عبد
المنعم عرفت التفاصيل لا قد تكون التعليق
عليها قاصر انما في شيء هام انا اتصور انه
كمل بردماتيه السعوديه والصينيه ستجعلنا
نتاكد انها ليست اتفاقيات ورقيه وليست
اتفاقيه انشائيه شاهدنا مثلها الكثير
الكثير السابق انا اتصور انه الطرفين ما
حضروا اوراق وله اوراق من قبل القيادات
الا هناك شبه يقين بانها اتفاقيات ذاهبه
للتطبيق وبالتالي اشهدها قريبا ستظيرها
ارقام التبادل التجاري
زادت ااا تضاعفت عمليات تبادل تجاري بين
السعوديه والمنطقه والصين 620 مره من خلال
العقود القليله الماضيه وبالتالي نحن
نتكلم عن اقتصاد صيني فاعل نتكلم عن رتبه
خليجيه حقيقيه ورقم السعوديه بالتحول الى
الاقتصاد الحقيقي بمساعده الصين فهنا
كماسب للطرفين وبالتالي هذا الامر يجعلنا
نتفائل كثيرا بالاتفاقيات اليوم من
المعروف ان الصين هي القوه الاقتصاديه
الثانيه الكبرى في العالم وربما في طريقها
همم ان تكون في المرتبه الاولى في صداره
الدول الاقتصاديه الكبرى في العالم
وبالتالي نحن همم والعالم العربي بحاجه
اليها لكن بالنسبه للصين
اين تحتاج العالم العربي اين تحتاج الخليج
ايضا كذلك ما الذي تريد ان تطوره من
علاقات من شراكات في اي مجالات برايك
دكتور طبعا الصين لازم ندرك انها عجله
انتاجيه جباره باكثر مما عرفه التاريخ في
اي منطقه اخرى من من العالم
لانها تقع تحت قياده مركزيه صينيه
وتحولت بفعل التكنولوجيا والعمل الشاق
وغيره الى المرتبه اللي احنا بنتحدث عنها
الان هذه المرتبه تحتاجوا اسواق
العالم العربي فيه وبما فيها في المرحله
الحاليه بعد ازمه الطاقه العالميه اصبح
مؤهلا تماما انه يكون سخن كبيره لمنتجات
صينيه هذه المره المنتجات الصينيه ليست
قائمه على انه تفقد تفتح ابواب للتصدير
دون ان تاخذ
المقابل من خلال فتحه اسواقها الداخليه
ايضا هناك امور انا اتشوق ان انظر
الاتفاقيات لان الصين احيانا
تحقق يعني
احتكارا عايز اقوله للسلع ذات الطبيعه
الرخيصه نسبيا فينتج عنها باستمرار عجز في
الميزان التجاري لصالح الصين يعني فيما
عدد دول العربيه النفطيه التي همم بفعل
حتى ارتفاع اسعار النفطه ايضا لديها فائض
في التعامل مع مع الصين لكن بقيه الدول
العربيه في الحقيقه يوجد عجز ويوجد عجز
فاتح هذا العجز جزء منه ان الصين عليها ان
تعدل نمط الانتاج الحادث معها بحيث يتماثل
مع الدول المتقدمه كثير من الصناعات زي
الملابس زي المصنوعات الجلديه زي زي
الاطفال نعم تتحدث على التجاره الحره
زي ما حصل مع دول متقدمه واخرى انسحبت من
مجالات كامله والصين تحدثت ذلك لكن لم
تنفذه بعد لو احنا بنتكلم منها علاقات
العربيه الصينيه وليس السعوديه همم
الصينيه انما كالعالم العربي ككل جزء من
عمليه التفاعل مع الصين لابد ان يؤدي الى
اعاده ترتيب ال- ال- ال- الاسواق الجاريه
بما فيها من عرض وطلب بما فيها من صادرات
وواردات يبقى هل يمكننا نختزل الصين في
الاقتصاد في التجاره في اا انها علاقه
ربما بينها وبين الخليج علاقات مشتري همم
وبائع ام هناك ما هو ابعد سامي
وابعد حتى التاريخ انا يعني قبل ايام قالت
طلع لا رحلت مثلا سليمان التاجر قبل 1200
سنه منذ ذلك الوقت والصينيين يقولوا
بالكتاب انهم يهتمون فقيرهم وقنيهم كبيرهم
وصغيرهم بالقراءه والتعلم كذا يعني امه لا
تتقافى وعندها يعني همم قدر على ان
تساعدنا في عمليه النهضه تعلم ان التعليم
بالوطن العربي من الاسود للمعلومه انا
بالاربعه والتسعين كنت في جزيره شيماء في
في في الصين والتقيت حوالي 20 شاب سعودي
بذاك الوقت المبكر من اراكم كانوا يتالمون
الصينيه واعتقد الان فيه
الان في هذا التوجه بس اتفاقيات اليوم
لتعليم اللغه الصينيه
يعني ادخال ماده اللغه الصينيه في عدد
المدارس
الدكتور عبد المنعم قضيه الاسواق سواء
الصينيه الكوريه اليابانيه دائما هم
يذهبوا للتصدير لك انما يحاولوه بقدر
الامكان ان يحد من تصدير كلهم بل حتى
عندما تصدر لهم حتى لو تطوعت القوانين
عندهم للتصدير تجد عزوف المواطن عندهم من
شراء هذه البضاعه وبالتالي دول الخليجيه
لا اشكال لديها الماده الخامسه تذهب الى
هناك بحكم التوسع الصناعه انما علينا كذلك
اخوه واشقاء مع الدول العربيه ان يحاول
انه ساهم بتعديل الاتفاقيات الصينيه
العربيه بحيث يكون هناك من فعل متبادله
يعني ستظار الدول العربيه اذا فتحت
اسواقها للمنتج الصيني اللي قادر على
تدمير صناعه المحليه تعرف همم اخي الفاضل
انه ما عاد هناك وطنيه بالتصنيع يعني لن
تجد سوري ولا مصري ولا كذا يقول والله
هاشتري الطاوله هذه لانها مصريه لو ادفع
فيها في الثمن لا هذا الامر ما عدا قائما
وبالتالي اذا ما تعمل اتفاقيه متوازنه
بحيث نستفيد ومن الصين وتستفيد الصين من
صادرات الصناعه العربيه نعتقد ان هناك
اشكال حقيقي بهذه العلاقه حدث ذلك انا
اتصور انه الانفتاح على الصين همم الامر
القائم حتى يقال انه الدوله العباسيه كان
لديها 15 سفير في مقاطعه مختلفه من الصين
منذ ذلك الوقت المبكر ويمكن حتى تتحدث عن
ناس سامي اليوم همم الرئيس الصيني في
مقاله تحدث بان تاريخ التواصل بين الصين
والدول العربيه يعود لما قبل اكثر من الفي
سنه استشهد بطريق الحرير البل- البري
التبادلات الكثيره بين التجار
والمسافرين تحدث عن طريق التوابل البحري
همم السفن الشراعيه تحدث عن الحضارات
الحضاره الصينيه والعربيه في طرف القرار
ربما قرات هذا المقال الدكتور عبد المنعم
واا يعني كان هناك ما هو مبطن من رسائل في
هذا المقال المطول والذي تتحدث فيه عن عدد
من طبعا النقاط المهمه فيما يخص علاقه
الصين بالسعوديه او بالخليج او بالعالم
العربي كيف قراته دكتور
الصيني يكتب في صحيفه عربيه قبل ان ياتي
الى الى هنا يعني عندما فعل بيض ذلك كتب
مقالا في واشنطن بوست باللغه الانجليزيه
ويقعد فيها الشعب الامريكي انه سوف يحافظ
على القيام الامريكيه عندما ياتي
في اشاره مقتنه الى او اعاده صياغه فلسفه
الايديولوجيه تجاه العالم انما هنا لدينا
مقالا مقروءا باللغه العربيه في جريده
الرياض السعوديه العربيه من هنا احنا
لدينا طريقه مختلفه في السلوك لكن ايضا
علينا ان احنا احنا نسمع الرساله بتاع
التبادل مع الصين وانا اعرف الحكمه
النبويه القائله اطلب العلم حتى لو في
الصين على ذلك
الصين كانت يعني مكانا للبحث والعلم في
العالم لكن احنا عندنا نعرف ان ابن بطوطه
ذهب الى الصين لكن لا نعرف من هو الصين
الذي جاء لدينا موجود
نحتاج الى نوم من المعرفه بهذا التاريخ
ليس فقط للمبارزه والمباسه مع مع الصينيين
لكن بعث العلاقات التاريخيه القائمه على
السلام القائمه على التجاره
ليصبح جزء من ثقافه المرحله وانا اقول ذلك
لان الصين تدخل على مرحله جباره من
التطورات التكنولوجيا يعني التعاون مع مع
الصيني يتعدى بكثير فكره البينج بونج اللي
كنا بنتكلم على من شويه انما هي فكره انك
انت الصين النهارده ما بتخش في مجالات
جديده بيبقى السرعه بتاعتها همم يعني سرعه
كبيره جدا الان تدخل في مجالات سواء
المتعلقه بالفضاء بشكل اا غير عادي ومنفع
وقوي كل نتائج الثوره الرابعه اللي بنتحدث
عنها من اول سواء في الانفورماتيكس او في
الاقتصاد الاخضر او او غيره انا اعتقد
الصين بتقدم لنا سوق تكنولوجيه همم همم
مبهره وملهمه في نفس الوقت خاصه وانه ده
ما توافقنا عليك دول عربيه في حاله اصلاح
على انه هو دورنا العالمي في هذه المرحله
يعني كلمه ان الشرق الاوسط يكون اخضر ليست
مجرد شعارا سياسيا وانما في حاجه من
الاوباسيتي الفاعليه اللي موجوده اللي
بتخلي ان ذلك يتم وبيتم وفق برنامج الزمن
مدينه نفس المساله نعملها مع الصين انا
اشكرك جزيل الشكر على مشاركه في هذا
الحوار الدكتور عبد المنعم سعيد الواحد
السياسي والكاتب السياسي ايضا بشكل جيد
لها الاستاذ اسامه الناس في وزير الاعلام
الكويتيه همم السابق
مشاهدينا ال- كرام اختتموا همم معكم هذا
الجزء من هنا من نافذه العربيه التي همم
تتابع معكم لحظه بلحظه قمم الرياض تبعنا
منذ همم
ظهر اليوم اليوم وهو اليوم السعودي الصيني
الخالص طبعا باستقبال الرئيس الصيني همم
بشكل رسمي هذا اليوم بدات الزياره بشكلها
الرسمي همم كان في استقباله همم الامير
محمد بن سلمان ولي العهد السعودي رئيس
مجلس الوزراء وبعد ذلك عقدت مباحثات رسميه
بين همم الامير محمد بن سلمان والرئيس
الصيني توجهها بعد ذلك همم تسلم الدكتوره
الفخريه من جامعه الملك سعود
وكذلك عقد مباحثات رسميه ثنائيه مع العهد
السعودي الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز وقع
معه في هذه المباحثات على اتفاقيه الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه الشامله بين البلدين بحضور
ولي العهد الامير محمد بن ايمان وعدد من
الاتفاقيات في مجالات
الاسكان والمجالات التقنيه همم كذلك ايضا
التعليم
وتشجيع الاستثمار ايضا وعدد من الاتفاقيات
التي تم الاعلان عنها اصل هنا الى نهايه
هذه النافذه من العاصمه السعوديه الرياض
عود مره اخرى الى الزملاء في اا دبي والى
الدكتور طالب كان عند الدكتور تفضل شكرا
لك نايف وهمم لضيف فائق على هذه التغطيه
يعطيك الف عافيه
نشاطها الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
ردود فعل دوليه ممدده باعدام ايران احد
المتظاهرين بعد محاكمه وصوره
اهلا بكم من جديد شددت منظمه حقوق الانسان
الايرانيه على ضروره ان يكون هناك رد فعل
قوي وعواقب دوليه سريعه ضد السلطات
الايرانيه بعد تنفيذ حكم الاعدام بحقه احد
المحتجي وقالت المنظمه ان السلطات نفذت
حكم الاعدام بحق المتظاهر محسن شكاري بعد
محكمه صوريه لم تستند الى اي اجراءات
قانونيه
وذكرت وكاله تسليم الايرانيه شبه الرسمي
عند المحكمه العليا رفضت الاستئناف الذي
قدمه المتهم وبررت الحكم بالقول ان افعاله
تمثل جريمه الحرابه
فرنسا المانيا بريطانيا دانت من جهتها
وبقوه اعدام السلطات لهذا المحتاج
ومع استمرار الاحتجاجات في ايران اعرب
الرئيس الاسبق محمد خاتمي عن تاييده
للاحتجاجات الشعبيه التي اشعلتها وفاه
الشابه محسن امين وحتى السلطات الايرانيه
على الاستجابه لمطالب المحتاجين قبل فوات
الاوان وقال خاتمي ان شعار المتظاهرين
المتمثل في المراه الحياه الحريه يشير الى
ان المجتمع الايرانيه يتجه نحو مستقبل
افضل
كما انتقد خاتم حمله الاعتقالات التي
تشنها القوات الامنيه ضد الطلاب المشاركين
في الاحتجاجات قائلا انه لا ينبغي السماح
بان تكون الحريه والامن في مواجهه بعضهما
البعض
افادت مصادر العربيه ان شركه طيران معراج
الايرانيه المرتبطه بالحرس الثوري تسير
رحلات الى مطار بيروت الدولي موضحا ان
رحلات الشركه الايرانيه الى لبنان قد تكون
تنقل اسلحه ومعدات حساسه لحزب الله
اسرائيل تكشف عن مسار جديد لتهريب سلاح
ايران الى ميليشيا حزب الله هذه المره عبر
خطوط معراج التابعه للحرس الثوري بشكل
الاسبوعي يشهد مطار بيروت الدولي هبوطه
رحلات ايرانيه تابعه لشركه معان اير
وايران لكن في الاسابيع الاخيره بدات شركه
معراج الايرانيه بتسيير رحلاتها الى لبنان
في نهج غير اعتيادي حطت الرحله الاولى في
الرابعه عشر من نوفمبر مصادر العربيه
افادت ان رحلات معراج لبيروت قد تنقل
اسلحه ومعدات حساسه لحزب الله وان اسرائيل
تخشن ضمامه مطار بيروت الى مسار تهريب
الاسلحه من ايران للبنان عبر هذه الرحله
المصادر اكدت ان هذا النوع من المحور في
نقل الاسلحه فيعرض لبنان للخطر عدا ان
استغلال مطار بيروت في نقل اسلحه ايرانيه
سيضر بالاقتصاد اللبناني وقد يعرض لبنان
للعقوبات والعزله الدوليه
على مر السنوات
القدس على نقل اسلحه من ايران الى سوريا
ومن هناك الى لبنان مثل مكونات انظمه
الدفاع جوي وصواريخ ارض ارض دقيقه بهدف
تعزيز دور مليشي حزب الله وتقويته بالسلاح
نقل المعدات الى لبنان يمر عبر محاوره
متعدده المحور البري وذلك باستخدام شاحنات
والمركبات وعبورها المعابر الحدوديه من
العراق الى سوريا المحور البحري باستخدام
السفن الايرانيه التي تبحر الى ميناء
اللاذقيه في سوريا والمحور الجوي من ايران
الى سوريا باستخدام الخطوط الجويه
الايرانيه ومن هناك الى لبنان عبر وكلاء
النقل التابعين لميليشيا حزب الله ملوك
الشيخ العربيه
بجسر القرم وهجمات اخرى قامت بها اوكرانيا
نور موسيقى هذا وقال سيرجيرياكوف نائب
وزير الخارجيه الروسي ان موسكو ستلتزم
بتعليق نشر الصواريخ النوويه متوسطه المدى
في اوروبا ماذا مات الولايات المتحده لم
تنشر مثل تلك الاسلحه في اوروبا واسيا
مشيرا الى ان التعليق المؤقت يمكن ان
يتغير في حال نشرت واشنطن صواريخ نوويه
متوسطه المدى
النوويه الروسيه ستكون في حاله تاهب
هذا مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جهاز بارال من ان المخزون
الاحتياطي للاسلحه الاوروبيه التي يتم
ارسالها الى اوكرانيا قد نفذ موضحا ان
نفاد احتياطي لاسلحه الاوروبيه سببه عدم
تلقي المجمع الصناعي العسكري الاوروبي
التمويل المناسب خلال السنوات الماضيه دار
الاضافه ان اجماليه لانفاق العسكري لدول
الاتحاد الاوروبي ارتفع بنسبه 6% في عام
2000 و 2021 وبلغ 200 24 مليار يورو
مؤكلان استعداد للاتحاد الاوروبي لتمويل
زياده انتاج الاسلحه والذخيره لتعويض
الاحتياط الاوروبي
نقل صحيفه عن مسؤولين غربيين ان الغربه
يتهم تركيا بتعطيل امدادات النفط الخام من
البحر الاسود دون اسباب تستدعي عرقله حركه
السفن في المضائق التركي
انه يجب على انقر ان تسمح بمرور السفن
التي تنقل معظم النفط من كازاخستان وقال
المسؤولون الغربيون ان ناقلات النفط الخام
البالغ عددها عشرون ناقله لا تخضعوا
شحناتها لقرار سقف الاسعار على النفط
الروسي
من جهاتي عربه نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي
الكسندر جروسكو عن قلق بلاده حول ناقلات
النفط الروسيه قباله سواحل تركيا
نشرت الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
الشرطه الالمانيه تتوقع مزيدا من
الاعتقالات على خلفيه محاولات الانقلاب
والتحقيقات تشمل 54
السلطات الالمانيه
في الايام المقبله على سلاطين بجماعات
يمنيه ويقول الادعاء انها كانت تستعد لقلب
نظام الحكم عبر استخدام العمر
وتوقع وزير الداخليه في ولايه تورنغن بشرق
المانيا جورج مايو موجه ثانيه من
الاعتقالات في ما اكد مدير مكتب الشرطه
الاتحاديه هوترنش ان عدد المشتبه بهم في
القضيه وصل الى 54 شخصا وان العدد مرشح
للارتفاع مضيفا ان الشرطه عثرت خلال
المداهمات على معدات تتنوع بين ستراتيه
واقواس وسهام وبنادق وذخيره فضلا عن ادله
على تجنيد الخريف
غلطه الفيضانات قريه النائيه في منطقه
جاوى بشمال الشرق نيجيريا وتسببت في تهجير
السكان وتتعرض القريه بسبب البنيه التحتيه
السيئه الى فيضانات الثانويه للمياه
الزائده من النهر المحلي
[موسيقى]
اعلن الاتحاد الاسباني لكره القدم اقاله
المدرب لويس الامريكي من منصبه بعد الخروج
المبكر من نهائيات كاس العالم لكره القدم
وقد خرجت اسبانيا بطله العالم في العام
2010 من دوره 16 بعد خسارتها امام المغرب
بركلات الترجيح
هذا هو تلتقي يوم الجمعه منتخبات البرازيل
امام كرواتيا والارجنتين امام هولندا في
ما تلعب السبت منتخبات المغرب والبرتغال
وفرنسا ضد انجلترا
اكتشف العلماء حمض النوويه للحيوانات
ونباتات وميكروبات يعود الى قرابه
المليونير وهو اقدم حمض النووي مسجل على
الاطلاق في رواسبه باقصى نقطه من شمال
جرين لاند تم استخراجها حول مصب مضيق
بالمحيط المتجمد الشمالي
[موسيقى]
نشاط الخامسه من العربيه انتهتبقى التحيات
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]